Women's History Month a time of year
when internet trolls stop asking how
come there's no white History Month and
start asking how come there's no men's
History Month much like Black History
Month celebrating women seems like it
should be a year-round thing in the form
of equal pay and accessible abortion
instead of what ends up feeling like a
month-long consolation prize it's kind
of like when your boss makes you
employee of the month instead of giving
you a raise
thanks for the plaque in the cake but I
could also use some dental insurance
especially after that cake but I wonder
do we have to celebrate all women before
I go on let me just clarify that I am a
proud feminist as opposed to a
self-hating feminist unapologetic
feminist or your 17-year old cousin
Trish who like gets it but doesn't see
the point sure we should celebrate the
great ones
the Susan B's the Sojourner tea's the
Ruth Bader Gees and Fiona Apple but what
about the Kim DS the Michelle bees and
the Serapis you know the crap ones the
ladies who've actively worked against
women's rights and human rights in
general the ones who've stood on the
shoulders of our foremothers
only to kick them in the head and say
thanks for that booze bitch some say
they're protecting life we're the party
with the plank that protects even our
littlest sisters in the womb
while consistently making life more
unlivable as I oppose the federal
government mandating paid maternity
leave to every company and still find
time to incite violence against Muslims
in between tanning sessions get a gun by
one legally learn how to shoot it and be
primed to use it
you go girl no really get the out
of here I guess what I'm trying to say
is should we celebrate the ladies who
have turned back the clock on women's
history that is a little bit
quick focus on me I think what my friend
here is trying to say is it's
problematic to celebrate women who have
used their influence to fight against
women's interests as a whole and while I
celebrate your right to express your
opinions Francesca I think you're
forgetting that women's herstory month
is also about recognizing those women
who have taken on patriarchy in order to
be able to perpetuate are you
mansplaining patriarchy to me yeah
these women are actually examples of
gender equality by demonstrating that
they too have the right to be
megalomaniacal sociopaths just like any
and many men yeah thanks Matt you know
maybe you're right
or maybe you're just overly confident
whichever it is perhaps we should
celebrate these groundbreaking sellouts
but how welcome to the 2016 Margaret
Thatcher Awards this is the night that
we celebrate the amazing women who have
shattered the glass ceiling and then use
the shards to stab us in the back how
far we've come
tonight's first category is for Best
Original about vaccines and the
Thatcher goes to what a snub to Jenny
McCarthy former US Representative
Michelle Bachman
this is Bachmann second Thatcher who
first was for best campaign pulled from
ass her little daughter took that took
that vaccine that injection and she
suffered from mental retardation
thereafter the next Thatcher presented
tonight is for outstanding achievement
in immigrant scapegoating and the
Thatcher goes to former Arizona Governor
Jan Brewer we were previously wanna
fetch her for her role in denying school
children comprehensive sex education
it's an invasion it's absolutely an
invasion of our country they're coming
here and they're bringing drugs and
they're doing drop houses and they're
extorting people and they're terrorizing
the families and finally for the
suffrage Sh'ma fridge award the winner I
could have guessed this one and Coulter
suppose you know my position is women
should not have the right to vote we can
still write books we run for office
you just can't vote exactly
congratulations you soulless off-brand
Barbie and that does it for the 2016
Thatcher Awards thank you especially to
our sometimes sponsor Hillary Clinton
reminder that maybe someday we'll live
in a world where women won't have to
play into patriarchy in order to get
ahead but until then there will always
be the Thatcher's good night
you